reaction former white house press
secretary fox news contributor kaylee
mcadaney
along with media columnist for the hill
joe concha fox news contributor
kayla you dealt with with the mob as i
call them on a regular basis
i mean imagine this i mean i started
laughing
when they said they wanted to go oh we'd
like to feature you on 60 minutes i said
oh yeah
okay i'm sure it's going to be fair and
balanced how about we do it live to tape
that wasn't an option kaylee
john i find that really interesting uh
what you just revealed there because
look
60 minutes had interviewed the president
back in 2016
and uh in 2020 they came back and said
let's interview him again and i will
never forget
walking into the interview the president
walks in
it was a total and complete hit job
every single
question was framed to trap him attack
him
take him down the exact same thing that
they tried to do to ron desantis who
in fact did not interview with them but
because he wouldn't interview with him
they just
came to a press conference blindsided
him refused to take the words of
democrats
of democrats this is journalistic
malpractice sean by the way
you know of course the washington post
new york times their bias their leftists
they would come to me with a hit piece
against the president ask for my
response as press secretary i'd give it
to them
but even they would include a snippet of
my response
60 minutes would not even include a
snippet of the response from democrats
refuting the story
this is egregious it disseminates our
our any respect we have for journalism
and we all need to take a very hard look
at journalism in the united
it is in a perilous perilous place now
publix is a great grocery chain joe they
really are i know
i'm very well aware of them great stores
great shopping
anyway so when the mayor of palm beach
county and and other officials met with
ron desantis desantis laid out all the
options
it was the mayor that made that decision
he told me on my radio show today
by the way i give this democratic mayor
all the credit in the world he put
people in his county before
politics they work together everyone
says they want bipartisanship here you
actually had it
publics they didn't charge the state of
florida a penny
they donate to republicans they donate
to democrats they donate to all causes
pretty much equally from what we've been
able to determine
if i was publix now we have times v
sullivan the fact that they
intentionally
kept out that exculpatory information
from multiple democrats saying
your narrative is false they were told
i think might actually meet the high bar
standard of malice
thoughts that's interesting if ron
desantis goes
down that route but in this polarized
timeline
and desantis i think they should both
sue
well it's a very good point that the
publix is not happy about this as well
given the statement
that they put out but we're so divided
now it's so rare to see
a democrat defend a republican like ron
desantis
a very viable 2024 candidate who could
very easily take the nomination
particularly if donald trump does not
win
and here you have democrats in the state
defending ron desantis
but look the central focus of this
report was why was
publix chosen in this situation 60
minutes says pay for play
but how could that be if they donate to
both parties and even to progressive
causes but also we're supposed to
believe that 100k
buys you the sitting governor of florida
that dog don't hunt particularly when he
has presidential aspirations as i just
mentioned
where if he gets the nomination if he
gets the nomination
you're talking about two billion dollars
compared to a hundred thousand
it's it's ridiculous on its face but
let's talk about the facts here for a
second
publix is also doing the vaccination
efforts and helping the lead
in states like alabama georgia south
carolina texas virginia
didn't hear that in the 60 minutes piece
publix isn't more than kaylee knows this
800 locations in florida it is as
ubiquitous
as a starbucks in new york so if you
want to get this out to the community in
particular the elderly
this is the number one company that you
go to and speaking of number one
axios and harris did a poll in 2020 and
found that publix is the number one most
trusted company
in the country so here's the top line
headline that should have been included
in this piece of 60 minutes actually
want to be objective
cases since the beginning of the year
among those over 65
are down 80 percent in the state of
florida they're down 53
when we're talking about
hospitalizations and the fact that
60 minutes has andrew cuomo in his
backyard who's under two investigations
on a federal level and on a state level
as far as a cover-up around nursing home
deaths
nine women accusing him of sexual
harassment and the fact that he
prioritized is wrong when no one can get
them at the beginning of this pandemic
for his brother and other people
in his family i'm sorry this is me now
intense and
biased in broad daylight as if we've
ever seen it sean sorry go ahead
last word we have about 20 seconds
kaylee
yeah look you you mentioned something
there on the fly sean about new york v
sullivan that case it's just really
important to point out that the standard
is so
high to hold any of these news
organizations accountable you have to
prove intentional malice
it is extremely hard to prove it's why
60 minutes it's why the left msnbc cnn
they get away with murder each and
every day they can say whatever they
want because you can't hold them
accountable it's a travesty
even antonin scalia uh said just that
and he was exactly right all right thank
you both